Protecting sensitive health data
divides into three sub areas.
Privacy in health care means
that only individuals or
entities authorized by the patient
may have access to their data.
So a patient's record may be stored
digitally in the EHR of a hospital, but
that doesn't mean anyone in
the hospital can access it.
It can only be accessed by people
authorized for specific purposes.
Security is preventing
unauthorized access to the data by
outsiders such as hackers.
This is a particular concern
where data is being shared.
Just as with financial records,
health data has value and
must be protected at all times and
in all places where it resides.
Trust means knowing
that the individual or
entity with whom is being shared
is who they say they are.